Hello I’m Simon Whistler, you’re watching
the Today I Found Out YouTube channel, and
in the video today if you’ve ever wondered
how deaf people think, in terms of their inner
voice, well, you’re not going to wonder
for much longer.
Those who were born completely deaf and only
learned sign language will, not surprisingly,
think in sign language.
What is surprising is those who were born
completely deaf but learn to speak through
vocal training will occasionally think not
only in the particular sign language that
they know, but also will sometimes think in
the vocal language they learned, with their
brains coming up with how the vocal language
sounds.
Primarily though, most completely deaf people
think in sign language.
Similar to how an "inner voice" of a hearing
person is experienced in one's own voice,
a completely deaf person sees or, more aptly,
feels themselves signing in their head as
they "talk" in their heads.
For those deaf people who are not completely
deaf or wear devices to allow them to hear
somewhat, they will often experience more
vocal language in their "inner voice" in proportion
to how much they can hear.
Interestingly, deafness is significantly more
serious than blindness in terms of the effect
it can have on the brain.
This isn't because deaf people's brains are
different than hearing people, in terms of
mental capacity or the like; rather, it is
because of how integral language is to how
our brain functions.
To be clear, "language" here not only refers
to spoken languages, but also to sign language.
It is simply important that the brain have
some form of complex language it can fully
comprehend and can turn into an inner voice
to drive thought.
More specifically, language is integral in
such brain functions as memory, abstract thinking,
and, fascinatingly, self-awareness.
Language has been shown to literally be the
"device driver", so to speak, that drives
much of the brain's core "hardware".
Thus, deaf people who aren't identified as
such very young or that live in places where
they aren't able to be taught sign language,
will usually be significantly handicapped
mentally until they learn a structured language,
even though there is nothing actually wrong
with their brains.
The problem is even more severe than it may
appear at first because of how important language
is to the early stages of development of the
brain.
Those completely deaf people who are taught
no sign language until later life will often
have learning problems that stick with them
throughout their lives, even after they have
eventually learned a particular sign language.
It is because of how integral language is
to how our brains develop and function that
deaf people were long thought of as inherently
mentally handicapped and unteachable.
In fact, until around the 1970s, it was still
widely thought that the majority of deaf people
were at least mildly mentally handicapped.
How could this be when they had various sign
languages and even vocal training to allow
their brains to develop and function properly?
The problem stemmed from the fact that it
was decided at the International Congress
on Education of the Deaf that took place in
1880 in Milan that deaf people should not
use sign language; rather, they should be
forced to use spoken language almost exclusively.
This seems reasonable enough on the surface,
as deaf people are fully capable of learning
spoken language and this would allow them
to more completely integrate into the hearing
world, which is what spurred these educators
to make this momentous decision.
The problem with this was only recently discovered
and, indeed, many of the negative implications
are only just now being understood.
It turns out, while there are certainly exceptions,
most completely deaf people who are forced
to use only spoken language are only slightly
better off than those who know no language,
in terms of the development of certain brain
functions.
The first research showing the failure of
the oral method was done by Cambridge Professor
Ruban Conrad in the 1970s via testing reading
ability in deaf teenagers trained in said
method.
He discovered that while the average fully
deaf teenager could read individual words
at about an eight year old level, they read
without much understanding, particularly when
it came to taking in the meaning of a full
sentence.
The problem was that they had not adequately
been able to develop an "inner voice" due
to being restricted to oral language which
they could not hear.
Thus, without the inner voice, there was no
auditory imagery to linger in short term memory
while they took in the whole sentence.
In the general case, the fully deaf taught
only the oral method do gain significantly
more sense of self and better memory and the
like over those who have no language at all,
but in this state, they will never fully reach
their brain's potential as in when they learn
sign language.
The leading theory behind why those completely
deaf people taught only vocal language don't
properly develop an "inner voice" is that,
without being able to associate sounds with
the phonemes and complete words, the language
is too abstract and a brain without language
already struggles with things that are abstract.
Those deaf people who learn sign language,
however, have less trouble with comprehending
vocal language and, as noted earlier, have
the ability to have an "inner voice" that
speaks.
This is thought to be because, once the brain
has a structured language from which to more
or less "run" off of, similar to a computer’s
operating system, abstract concepts can be
more easily grasped; thus, comprehending vocal
language sounds and text becomes significantly
easier.
Because of these findings, the "oralist" method
of teaching the deaf that had endured for
just under a century began being rapidly phased
out in favor of a "bilingual" education where
sign language is taught as early as possible
and vocal language is taught as a sort of
secondary language.
As noted by Miranda Pickersgill, chief of
deaf services for Leeds Local Education Authority,
"Bilingualism is still very much a hot potato.
We have come in for a lot of flak and been
accused of pushing deaf children into a signing
ghetto.
Yet the deaf had a big price to pay when the
old methods failed.
Not only could they not communicate, but they
were left without a code to think in.
We can no longer ignore what the research
tells us."